we're sitting as a poms and I'm with
oxygen and I told him he's following me
are you following me keep popping you're
slowing down you're going all right it's
all going too fast it's I just see not
icarly I know my wife I know I'm
following here I'm bullying both you
guys you're following me
actually it's just really a billboard to
follow so what happened was is it we you
know we got in that whole CNN thing and
we were doing that the awareness
campaign for malaria no more and and
this guy who was a billboard company
went out and like just like in order to
support it could see who's behind
blaring no more in the whole thing we
bought all these billboards across the
country like follow a plus K and I was
like what like this was super bananas on
my phone yeah I use tweet we can also
use the desktop sometimes I talk about
Twitter all day but please talk about
Twitter all day there is a rumor that
you coming out that's true because
everybody else running around here has
seen it so can you just give me and what
are they telling you about it all right
so they're telling me that you're a
player yeah a little bit
you know he's a social grifter he's a
social sexual grifter
scary can you define a social sexual
drifter well he sort of sleeps with the
women and has a bit of a planning system
then he's built for himself
and he and he does it with the intention
of having the place they live and having
someone who will take care of them so he
sleeps with wealthy women in an effort
to have a place and to let them take
care of him so he's like trying to find
a sugar mama
[Music]
what
a lot of nudity
yeah when you do bad things bad things
come so is there anything that we should
expect going into this nor nothing about
the film that you know relation look for
well I think the key to the film is that
it's sexy and it's funny and it's
interesting and there are a lot of
really super smokin hot girls in it and
and and it's really it's sort of a party
and and so it has the good part of the
party and then it has the end of the
party that isn't always this good when
you're bad bad things happening so
there's this a question that I asked
pretty much everyone that I meet okay
are you ready what is your favorite
treat to be anything Oh food
is that what you're thinking I'm
thinking food okay okay you can go on
the right track oh good my favorite
treat I was in Mexico once and I was in
in a place in word of my yard up and
there was a chef in the place that I was
saying in the mid this like coconut
caramel graham cracker thing yeah I
don't even know what it is and I've been
chasing it ever since I had it like I
had it there and I took some and I like
box them up brought lunch back when they
put in the freezer so it lasted like a
month and I kept like like I would have
like one a week for like a month and
they're all gone now I don't get it
anymore it makes me crazy like I
actually Jones for this thing so that's
my favorite this is so good so on a
separate note aside from the treats I
hear that you're also working on a bunch
of different social media aspects that
are kind of gonna take away the movie
promotions from like the big guy is kind
of just a more do-it-yourself grassroots
approach it's gonna take the way from
the big guys you know my feeling is is
that
you know the traditional advertising on
the web like billboards and things like
that are really lame and like people are
sort of over it and then my other
feeling is that like you know people put
movie trailers on the web and and and
it's really used the content web is used
for like promotional purposes but
nobody's really getting any new good
real content on the web
so like taking Flickr and taking
Facebook and taking Twitter and taking
you know some video hosts YouTube or
whatever it may be and actually putting
them in one environment so yeah so we've
watched a little bit of the different
online campaign because look you can buy
you look you can you can consume the
promotion and the experience online and
then you can actually buy your movie
ticket online as well so you don't
really have to point people in all these
different directions so thank you so
much for taking a few minutes to chat
with me and I'll see you all right
[Music]